samurai roboter kämpfen meister dritter
märz toter in deutschland ein mit
verdunstung energie angetriebenes
spielzeugauto das sind nur drei der fünf
themen jetzt lediglich zum 250 die frage
nach leben auf dem mars beschäftigt
wissenschaftler schon seit jahren jetzt
sind forscher die antwort wahrscheinlich
ein ganzes stück näher gekommen
die nasa konnte mit hilfe des mars
reconnaissance orbiter lro
glasablagerungen auf dem mars entdecken
seit neun jahren kreist die sonde der
nasa um den mars vor kurzem konnte diese
sonde lichtreflektionen auf dem roten
planeten analysieren forscher konnten
aus den reflexionen schließen dass sich
auf dem mars glas rückstände befinden
diese seien durch kollisionen entstanden
bei einer kollision entstehe eine solch
starke hitze das gesteins teile
schmelzen und sich zu glas ähnlichen
elementen formen wissenschaftler der
brown university in providence hatten
nach argentinien bereits aus glas uralte
organische und pflanzliche moleküle
schöpfen können diese entdeckung im glas
sei mit einer der gründe warum man nach
glas auf dem mars sucht man erhofft sich
dadurch der frage gibt es leben auf dem
mars näher zu kommen
in südkorea treibt seit wochen einen
virus sein unwesen schon 20 menschen
sind an dem erkältungs ähnlichen virus
märz gestorben märz ist ein virus der
starke atemwegsinfektionen
lungenentzündungen und nierenversagen
auslösen kann südkorea kämpft derzeit am
heftigsten gegen diesen erreger an auf
deutschem boden sind bisher drei fälle
von einer märz erkrankung bekannt 2013
reiste ein 73 jahre alter mann aus den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten an
er starb an den folgen des virus in
essen konnte ein betroffener den erreger
überwinden
am samstag den 6 6 2015 starb ein
weiterer 65 jähriger mann in deutschland
anfang des jahres hatte dieser einen
auslandsaufenthalt in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten von dort hat er
vermutlich den erreger mitgebracht
er wurde mehrere wochen in einem
krankenhaus behandelt konnte märz soweit
besiegen starb dann aber leider ein
anderer an einer anderen infektion in
folge von merz
laut dem krankenhaus sei keinerlei
gefahr für andere menschen entstanden
sie haben über 200 personen die im
kontakt mit dem mann in der zeit
getreten sind gecheckt und konnten
keinerlei positive getestet darunter
finden
ein unkontrollierter ausbruch ist in
deutschland also wohl vorerst nicht zu
befürchten starke und ausstehende
schmerzen im unterleib hatte ich selber
schon mal könnte ein problem mit dem
blinddarm seien sofort zum arzt
wer schon einmal eine
blinddarmentzündung hatte der kennt
diese höllische schmerzen aktuell werden
diese blinddarm komplikationen operabel
gelöst der wurmfortsatz also in sehr
kleine blinddarm wird vom blinddarm vom
darm getrennt und herausgenommen wenn
man diesen fortsatz bei einer entzündung
nicht rechtzeitig entfernt kommt es zu
einem durchbruch also der domplatz und
infektionen im innern des körpers können
die folge dieses durchbruch sein
forscher aus finnland haben eine
operation aber nicht mehr nötig sie
sehen antibiotika als neues mittel zum
zweck ihre these haben sie auch direkt
aus getestet mit rund 500 probanden
führten sie ihre studie durch alle
hatten eine einfache blinddarmentzündung
per zufallsprinzip wurden sie in zwei
gruppen aufgeteilt die eine gruppe 273
personen wurde operiert und die andere
256 personen bekam antibiotika alle aus
der ersten gruppe bis auf eine person
bei der die entzündung schon vor der op
schwächer wurde konnten nach der
operation komplikationslos nach hause
bei der zweiten gruppe zeigte das
antibiotikum sehr positive auswirkungen
ganze 186 probanden konnten mit hilfe
des medikaments ihre blinddarmentzündung
wieder loswerden zu einer revolution in
der behandlung von blinddarm-operation
kommt es vorerst aber nicht
es gibt noch zu wenige berlin belegbare
erkenntnisse über um eine
antibiotika-therapie auf diesem feld
einsetzen zu können müsse man noch viel
mehr und vor allem viel umfangreichere
studien durchführen
vor allem müsste man klären welche
methode verträglicher ist op oder
medikation wenn eltern ihren kindern
spielzeuge schenken müssen sie meistens
sofort funktionieren sonst sind sie
erstmal total uninteressant
spielzeugautos kamen bisher immer mit
einem entscheidenden nachteil der akku
war leer wenn das auto zu seiner
besitzerin
sein besitzer kam also uninteressant
forscher aus den usa haben jetzt ein
antrieb für spielzeug autos entwickelt
der ganz ohne jede akkuleistung
betrieben werden kann diese motoren
laufen autonom wenn sie an grenzflächen
zwischen wasser und luft platziert
werden berichtet das team der new yorker
columbia university im nature
communications magazin treibstoff des
antriebs die spuren des holzes das
bremer an diese sporen ist dass sie sich
je nach luftfeuchtigkeit aus denen
beziehungsweise zusammenziehen können
und das ruckartig diese kontraktion bzw
entspannung ähnelt der eines
menschlichen muskeln und da sind wir
auch schon bei der energie für den
antrieb muskelkraft setzt ja schließlich
auch energie frei in einer kiste
verbauten die wissenschaftler folien die
mit den sporen verkleidet worden wenn
die luftfeuchtigkeit in der kiste steht
wähnten sich die sporen aus eben
schlagartig die folie spannte sich
sobald die feuchtigkeit weniger wurde
zogen sich die sporen zusammen und die
folie schlug falken über dem erdboden
finden durchgehend sogenannte
verdunstung prozesse statt ständig
steigt verdunstende wasser nach oben
durch diesen prozess gelangt dann auch
die feuchtigkeit in die kiste der
forscher ohne deren zutun
mit hilfe der daraus resultierende
bewegungen konnten die forscher
erreichen dass sogar klappen an der
seite der kiste damit geöffnet bzw
geschlossen worden spuren folien und die
luftfeuchtigkeit erzeugen damit
muskelkraft dieser muskel ermöglichte es
ihnen dann auch ein spielzeugauto mit
dieser technik anzutreiben verzichten
wir also demnächst auf das lästige
warten bis der akku für das so geliebte
spielzeugauto geladen ist
ein samurai roboter kämpft wie ein
echter meister unfassbar wie schnell und
kraftvoll roboter mittlerweile sind eine
im filmgeschäft viel benutzte technik
mode in motion capture verleite einem
roboter das können eine samurai die
japanische firma yaskawa electric
corporation ist dieses jahr 100 jahre
alt geworden
anlässlich dieses geburtstages haben sie
einen ihrer eigenen industrieroboter
etwas umfunktioniert eigentliche aufgabe
eines solchen roboters karosserien oder
ähnliches zusammenschrauben oder lack
ihren ausgerüstet wurde der motor nh24
mit einem katana und den capture
aufnahmen des aoc maschine so matschie
ist fünffacher weltrekordhalter und
meister in der schwertkampf technik die
ja zu in den ersten versuchen traten die
beiden kontrahenten erst einmal in einer
etwas leichteren disziplin an dem
diagonalen schnitt der roboter trennte
wie auch der meister ohne probleme die
bambus matten mit einer unfassbaren
geschwindigkeit imitierte der roboterarm
denen des meisters im letzten versuch
galt es 1000 schnitte durchzuführen
die bambus matten wurden aufgestellt die
kontrahenten stellten sich in die
startposition und legten los
während der meister ordentlich zu
schnaufen hatte schnitt der roboter
fröhlich vor sich hin und zeigte wer
hätte es anders erwartet keinerlei
anzeichen von müdigkeit am ende konnten
beide sowohl der roboter als auch der
meister 1000 schnitte erfolgreich
absolvieren das pr video zeigt ganz klar
roboter sind extrem belastbar und
flexibel einsetzbar
eins können sie aber noch nicht
eigenständig sein vielleicht werden wir
menschen schon bald mit roboter
ähnlichen extremitäten oder zumindest
roboter ähnlichen bauteilen ausgestattet
wie man sich das vorstellen könnte das
könnt ihr hier im video hier oben sehen
zu rap und zum bock kommt ihr hier unten
und das haltet ihr vom fortschritt in
der robotertechnologie gut oder eher
schlecht sollten sie irgendwann mal
eigenständigkeit entwickeln können oder
besser nicht diskutiert es gerne mal in
den kommentaren und bis dann bleibt dran